[Musique]
ça swingue et ce samedi 9 juin au
château de plaisir ou une escale dans la
nouvelle orléans de louis armstrong
trombone clarinette banjo le jazz déçoit
si swingers à rythmer cette fin d'après
midi un groupe invité par la ville
effectivement j'avais déjà vu des
teasers j'ai vu également que d'autres
nantais était venu ici parce que voilà
les s'assied son garçon sont en tête et
bat en plus il fait beau donc cette
agréable les gens nous écoutent
[Musique]
j'ai aimé aussi bien le côté
instrumental que que là les mélodies que
les paroles c'était très bien autre
curiosité les jeux en bois pour les
enfants
la déambulation de cet oiseau à la
recherche de nourriture ou encore des
véhicules originaux construit à partir
de matières recyclées
à chaque fois il ya des nouvelles
propositions d'activités l'originalité
des des activités proposées
ça me fait du bien d'avoir un événement
comme ça chaque année à l'origine de ce
festival une légende un fantôme vivre et
à l'intérieur du château seuil à sainte
marie de la crâne qui était un corsaire
du roi louis xiii et il est parti loin
avec son bateau il nous a ramené des
coffres avec plein de choses différentes
du monde entier c'est pour ça qu'on a
créé escale d'ailleurs pour cette 17e
édition le corsair a fait une apparition
pour rencontrer les quelques 10000
visiteurs des escales d'ailleurs